so where you're going girl you can't
leave without coming inside
oh no I wouldn't want to be an intrusion
I just wanted to say hello goodbye there
is a seat in this house with your name
on it girl no no no no no no no no no no
no I can't I didn't have money for the
bus I'm a mess from the 50 mile walk
must you be so difficult girl you're
right I am being difficult aren't I your
life is better without me coming in
trust me so there I go okay girl listen
everything is Irene man we're good
friends all right of course you know you
can smell it girl you know you smell it
girl you know you're smelling the fried
dumplings Aki and a salt fish girl the
boys come over I should have cold I
should have called that's it too
I'm formally inviting you into my home
now come inside
foreign